joining me now before monday night
football with the new orleans saints
coming off of their bye week going to
seattle no
no easy assignment there obviously on a
monday night
from the new orleans saints on the
mercedes benz vans phone line linebacker
demario davis how are you sir
oh outstanding outstanding thanks for
having me on rich thanks for being on
what you do in your bi-week what does an
nfl player do in uh such an early bye
week with the longest regular season in
the history of regular schools well we
just had our fifth daughter uh child and
so
um
so we were just at home because you know
wife and and daughter couldn't leave so
we spent a lot of time
just here hanging out with the other
four kids taking them out to the movies
okay the museum just a lot of family
time so are you saying
if i picked that up correctly you're a
perfect five for five on daughters or
no no i i met fifth child okay
fourth daughter oh yeah four girls four
girls one boy oh
so you're outnumbered you're surrounded
let's be honest here oh yeah yeah yeah
but the girl dad is the great demario
davis
i i we had two boys first okay my wife
and i we had two boys first and she
turns to me she goes you need to be a
girl dad we need a girl i'm like really
she says really and i'm like being a
girl dad is the greatest thing of all
time this is everything brother
it is everything because when a girl
says something to you it's a wrap it
doesn't matter what it is it's a total
wrap oh yeah oh yeah they keep you
wrapped around their finger now okay so
you've got five kids and that's where
you that's not a bye week at all my god
that's work how many food
no that was good man i mean you know
during the season you don't get as much
time with the family of course
um just being able to be around them man
is very rewarding to mario davis being
three and two this team it's remarkable
with what you've already been through
what was it like oh gosh so you're you
were away from home for all that time
because of the hurricane and you're in
tcu and you're in texas and then you're
you're you've got a home game in
jacksonville with with five kids at home
that's what's going on with you
that's what happened
and that was that was an interesting
dynamic man my wife was pregnant during
that time and
uh they evacuated with us to dallas and
so we had poor and uh pregnant mom at
that time and then they came back a
little bit earlier than we did as a team
um so yeah it was a lot of transition
going on in that time and i i think
everybody was kind of going through it
together and so
it brought us closer as a team that's
what i was going to say what was that
like what was that like the beginning of
the season for you guys
oh man i think it was like for us like
an extended training camp was like we
never really got out of training camp
because it happened
uh right at the last preseason game and
so from there we had to pick up
and go and so we'd all been together all
that time and
uh had to continue in that that mode and
so and then the season was starting
you you know in this league nobody cares
about your problems you know some people
kind of glad you got them
and so we had to we had to dig deep and
just find a way and uh
you know we have a resilient team we're
it's a resilient city that we play for
and
uh we just found a way to think about
you know all those back home that had it
worse than than we did right and play
for them and and and that is uh that
helped us a lot during that time and
we've just got to continue that mindset
damari davis here before monday night
football with his saints taking on the
seahawks in a big week seven finale
what's it been like to watch jameis take
the reins here
to mario oh man
it's been phenomenal it's been
phenomenal when you look at
him and his history just just
a a very talented player
um has
always put up great numbers and i think
in this setup it it it requires him
to go to that next level in in the
efficiency department that's what we
need uh him to be to be highly efficient
he's he's been that for us um you know
that's kind of the formula for success
for us and uh you know he's done that in
a great way
um you know kept us on track managed the
game got into red zone score points
um as best as you could do it and you
know he played good football and it's
great to see him as a ascend as a a
player a person as a man as a leader
um so i'm excited to see that continue
to i think his best football is still in
front of yeah and and i mean to to to
now get another shot within the division
still too i mean like he's hardly you
know he hasn't moved to a new
neighborhood he's kind of moved down the
street a little bit right to the
neighbor that you didn't like and and uh
or from the neighbor you didn't like to
to you guys and so there wasn't much of
a transition period like do you have a
moment where he kind of had you
at hello in a way as a leader on this
team
to mario i think i think you know just
being able to see his story um you know
uh and kind of having gone through some
of those things myself you know i think
watching him
kind of take a a a humble route to to
come here and uh to be your first
overall pick been a starting quarterback
his whole career and then to
to pretty much know you're going into a
situation where you're gonna sit on the
bench for the entire year or so
um you know and doing that that would
have been very humbling but at the same
time
taking that and learning you know from
one of the greatest quarterbacks ever
played a game
kind of learning the culture learning
the environment
and
finding his own identity in the system
and
building that love for the city and now
it's his turn
and you know sometimes we have to take a
step back so that we can take a step
forward and you know just being able to
watch that
um and just be excited for his career
can go uh from this point you know it's
a pivotal it's a pivotal point in his
career and in his life so
it's been exciting to watch well i mean
i i don't like telling you what to do or
but i think it would be fun to do this
could you tell your teammates to be
quiet you're on the phone with rich
eisen and he's a very important man
would you mind doing that right now hey
y'all we all gotta be quiet man i'm on
the phone with rich eisen and very
important thank you very much
thank you very much and and are they are
they respectful of that right now how do
they look right now they say who is that
guy or what like how that works they all
give you they are giving you the face
like man who this dude
[Laughter]
i walked into that one guilty as charged
i walked into that pitch
oh my gosh demario davis here uh prior
to monday night football okay so the
challenge is like you know gino i mean
were you teammates with him demario back
in the day were you teammates with
genius yeah yeah yeah
so you were in there yeah i play i play
i played with him in new york he was uh
he was drafted while i was there right
okay so you know him and i think he's
he's in a new spot and obviously i think
uh more of a of a grown-ass man then
obviously with the young guy then you
you you saw drafted and all the
craziness that was surrounding them
there and you know
uh
what an opportunity this is for him what
is your challenge with this defense
taking on geno smith and a backup
quarterback wanting to make
obviously a name and a notch on his belt
at your expense demario yeah yeah it's
gonna be a great challenge he's had a
phenomenal career
um you know he's gotten better every
single year you can see in this game
it it's the reason why he's been in this
league this long um you build a great
career for yourself and um he's
definitely not playing like a number two
quarterback playing like a starter
um you know we know the talent is all
there
um
and it's been it's been you know
incredible i've you know been able to
because i played with him as a teammate
been able to follow his career the
entire time and i definitely know he's
stepping in again this game with a chip
on the shoulder with a point to prove
and
um you know and he's going to great
weapons and so uh and and they're well
coached we're going to play a really
good football team and a tough
environment so it's definitely going to
be challenging to say the least all
right so what do you what do you say to
people demario davis last one for you
here that okay you know you're in the
division where the the that you did win
last year but breeze is gone different
team breeze is gone i mean the number of
times that you could say that breeze is
gone that at least i hear that that thus
you're a different team and and the
bucks of the world champs and thus uh a
lot of folks are overlooking you how do
you how do you how do you and your team
respond to something like that to mario
davis
yeah man um you know for me i i look at
it i've been i've been i've been
underrated my whole life you know and so
um
you know the same people that that i
call you a horse i call you a mew and
some people call you a mule or call your
horse
you gotta say locked in and show up with
a point to prove every day
tamara davis i appreciate the time have
a great monday night football game let's
chat down the line appreciate it have a
good time in the locker room
all right man appreciate it all right
there you go there's demario davis and
his teammates right here before monday
night football between the saints
and the seahawks
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here